getting people in crisis the help they
need there is a new national hotline now
available to you if you're needing
assistance it's 988 the new national
suicide prevention hotline mental health
advocates say it is a major step toward
better access to therapy but how does it
work mary jane valley is joining us live
with details from a local organization
mary jane good morning
heather and john good morning to you
this is something mental health
advocates say is much needed and when
you dial 988 it will immediately connect
you to a crisis trained counselor in
your state nami of southern nevada's
executive director hopes this move will
push more people to get help as there
needs to be a bigger conversation on
destigmatizing mental health and
providing long-term care nami is not led
by clinicians or mental health providers
but people who have undergone mental
health struggles themselves
i think being part of a community once
we get to that point where we can give
back it's very empowering and that's
what we hear from a lot of our peers a
lot of our volunteers where you know
they might have started out in crisis
because whether it's their family
members or themselves and then they feel
comfortable because now they're in the
community where they're accepted
all of nami services are at no cost for
the community for long-term care that's
all funded through grants donations and
sponsorships and nami is also looking
for volunteers if you'd like to be part
of that bigger conversation surrounding
mental health reporting live from karen
and maryland parkway mary jane balleza
live local now